we start off by seeing him walking and
the things that Brad and I noticed right
away is again the the slight rounding of
the upper back y his shoulders slightly
go in yeah they're rounded they're also
rounded this way in and what's
interesting as he walks out he goes and
he gives his shoulders a little bit a
squeeze back like this he's trying to
inherently get it back into the right
position but again the shoulders are
rounded forward too some of this occurs
because the screens are just too low but
his keyboard's high too I mean yep his
keyboard's high too his arms don't even
touch his armrests and that's why those
armrests are there so you can rest and
relax your shoulders again he needs to
work on stretching his pectoralis major
and minor to stop that rounded out
shoulder that Hallelujah stretch that we
do yep and then chin tucks um in order
to bring the chin back if there's one
universal thing to say about everybody
who is on this these videos you got to
raise your screens yeah I mean they're
just too low